[Música]
el expresidente peruano Pedro Castillo
ratificó su solicitud de asilo en México
pero localmente avanza el proceso
judicial en su contra tras intentar
disolver el congreso Y cerrar la
fiscalía en lo que fue calificado de
autogolpe por los poderes del país hoy
la justicia le ordenó siete días de
prisión preventiva
ya está viajando de regreso a Estados
Unidos la basquetbolista
quien pasó 10 meses en una cárcel de
Rusia por llevar cartuchos con aceite de
Cannabis en su equipaje la deportista
Vuelve a casa después de un intercambio
que aprobó el presidente Joe biden en el
que devolvió a Moscú al Traficante de
armas ruso Víctor
y Croacia se une a la zona schengen a
partir del primero de enero de 2023
mientras zagreb celebra el aval de la
comisión europea para la libre
circulación Rumanía y Bulgaria rechazan
El veto emitido por Austria y siguen
Esperando ser aceptados
Bienvenidos a las noticias de France 24
yo soy María Clara calle
iniciamos con la noticia del momento en
América Latina el expresidente peruano
Pedro Castillo Pide al gobierno mexicano
que lo reciba bajo la figura de asilo
luego de que ayer el congreso lo
destituyó sin embargo la justicia
peruana le ordenó siete días de prisión
preventiva antes de que se adelante el
juicio en su contra por presunta
rebelión esto tras intentar según quedó
oficialmente establecido un autogolpe de
estado Andrés granadillo nos amplía
Castillo ratifica su solicitud de asilo
a México así lo informó el canciller
mexicano Marcelo ebrard desde su cuenta
de Twitter tras publicar la carta formal
de pedido el embajador Pablo Monroy me
reporta desde Lima que pudo
entrevistarse a las 13:20 horas con
Pedro Castillo en el centro
penitenciario lo encontró bien
físicamente y en compañía de su abogado
el presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel
López Obrador pidió garantías para
Castillo Entonces
nosotros pedimos que se le respeten sus
derechos humanos que se actúe
con legalidad verdadera
se protege a su familia más temprano en
Perú la corte ordenó siete días de
detención antes del juicio en su contra
por el presunto delito de rebelión se le
acusa por su intento de disolver El
Congreso cerrar la fiscalía y Llamar a
un gobierno de emergencia con toque de
queda y pedido de elecciones sin apoyo
de sus ministros el ejército las
autoridades judiciales el episodio
terminó con su arresto y la posesión de
sus vicepresidenta Dina boluarte como
nueva dirigente de Perú la primera mujer
en asumir este cargo de momento boluarte
descartó elecciones anticipadas Yo sé
que hay algunas voces que indican
adelanto de elecciones Y eso
democráticamente es respetable creo que
la Asunción de la presidencia en esta
oportunidad es un poco reorientar lo que
hay que hacer con el país más adelante
en coordinación con todas las
organizaciones
estamos viendo alternativas Mientras
tanto en Lima se mantienen algunas
manifestaciones de partidarios de Pedro
Castillo que piden su Liberación y
acusan a la nueva presidenta de traición
la vacancia por incapacidad moral que
argumentó el congreso de Perú para
destituir a Pedro castillo de la
presidencia es una figura con la que el
legislativo también presionó la salida
de otros dos mandatarios Martín vizcarra
y Pedro Pablo kuczynski y es que en los
últimos años la política peruana ha
estado marcada por la inestabilidad
política con seis presidentes en un
periodo de seis años a mal Venom nos
cuenta
en seis años Perú ha tenido seis jefes
de estado en 2020 el centrista Francisco
sagasti fue embestido como presidente
para garantizar la transición tras la
destitución de Manuel Merino quien duró
menos de una semana en el poder el
derechista ex jefe del Congreso se vio
obligado a dimitir en medio de protestas
contra su gobierno un Éxodo de su
gabinete y numerosas peticiones por su
dimisión Merino reemplazó a Martín
vizcarra quien fue destituido por el
congreso en 2020 después de que medios
de comunicación informa que recibió unos
640 mil dólares en sobornos por parte de
dos empresas que ganaron una licitación
de Obras Públicas cuando era gobernador
regional años antes en 2018 Pedro Pablo
kuczynski se vio obligado a dimitir de
la presidencia bajo la presión del
Congreso la fiscalía había abierto una
investigación en su contra por favorecer
contratos con la constructora brasileña
odebrecht cuando era ministro bajo el
mandato de Alejandro Toledo kuchinski
negó inicialmente Cualquier relación con
odebrecht pero el ex jefe de estado
acabó admitiendo que su consultora había
asesorado a la constructora en 2016 el
presidente ollanta humala fue a juicio
por acusaciones de que recibió 3
millones de dólares por parte de
odebrecht durante su campaña
presidencial de 2011 los fiscales
pidieron 20 años de prisión contrahumada
que siempre negó las acusaciones
Moscú y Washington protagonizaron un
intercambio de prisioneros en medio de
las tensiones que viven ambas naciones
la básquetbolista
ya está volando desde emiratos árabes
Unidos hacia Estados Unidos Mientras que
el que es considerado el mayor
Traficante de armas del mundo Víctor
Wood ya aterrizó en Moscú brainer fue
detenida en Moscú el 17 de febrero de
este año por llevar siete cartuchos de
vaporizador que contenían aceite de
cannabis algo que es legal en Estados
Unidos pero prohibido en Rusia
es libre así lo confirmó el presidente
estadounidense Joe biden escoltado por
la esposa de kriner su vicepresidenta y
el secretario de estado hace un momento
junto a su esposa sherell en la oficina
oval hablé con Britney wriner está a
salvo está en un avión está camino a
casa
grainer campeón olímpica de baloncesto
fue detenida en Rusia el pasado mes de
febrero por tener aceite de Cannabis en
su equipaje al entrar a ese territorio
en agosto fue condenada a nueve años de
cárcel por Contrabando y posesión de
drogas Estados Unidos ahora enfoca sus
esfuerzos en la liberación de Paul
Williams un exmarin acusado de espionaje
también arrestado en la nación
euroasiática el pasado 2018 después de
meses de detención injusta en Rusia está
de camino a casa con su esposa cherrell
y otros de sus seres queridos nos
estaremos en nuestros esfuerzos hasta
que Paul William también regrese con su
familia Britney fue intercambiada por
quien era considerado de los hombres más
buscados del mundo el ciudadano ruso
Víctor void un Traficante de armas
conocido como el mercader de la muerte
otra de las noticias en Estados Unidos
es que la cámara de representantes
aprobó un proyecto de ley que reconoce
los matrimonios de las personas del
mismo sexo a nivel federal y que ya
había sido avalado en el senado la
medida surgió de las preocupaciones que
generan un posible revés de la Corte
Suprema a este tipo de uniones la
historia la tiene Rafael Pérez
un paso importante para reforzar el
matrimonio igualitario en Estados Unidos
la cámara de representantes aprobó un
proyecto de ley que protege estas
uniones a nivel Federal un debate
acalorado se vivió en la sala Este es
otro paso más hacia la meta de los
demócratas de desmantelar la familia
tradicional silenciar las voces de la fe
y deshacer permanentemente el cimiento
de nuestro país tejido por Dios sería
incorrecto decir que mi esposo fill y yo
tenemos un matrimonio que es diferente
al matrimonio de cualquier otra persona
aquí en este cuerpo el seguro de salud
de mi centro de trabajo debe extenderse
a mi esposo al igual que el suyo se
extiende a su cónyuge la aprobación fue
aplastante así lo dio a conocer Nancy
pelosi en uno de sus últimos actos como
presidenta de la cámara
en esta votación los sí son 258 los no
son 169 se adopta la moción
la medida surgió de las preocupaciones
que generan un posible revés de la Corte
Suprema a este tipo de uniones como
ocurrió con legislación que permitía la
interrupción del embarazo el proyecto
promueve que el Gobierno Federal
reconozca el matrimonio entre dos
personas del mismo sexo si es legal en
el estado donde se casaron y además se
reconoce la libertad de religiosa tras
la aprobación el presidente Joe biden no
tardó en reaccionar en este día Jill y
yo estamos pensando en las parejas
valientes y los defensores
apasionadamente comprometidos que han
luchado durante décadas para garantizar
la igualdad en el matrimonio en todo el
país ante la Corte Suprema y en el
congreso si bien estamos un paso más
cerca de nuestro largo viaje para
construir una Unión más perfecta nunca
debemos dejar de luchar por la igualdad
total para los estadounidenses lgtbiq+ y
todos nuestros ciudadanos la ley fue
ratificada por el senado el mes pasado
ahora deberá ir al despacho oval para su
aprobación final por parte del
presidente Joe biden para que entre en
vigor
Croacia comenzará a ser parte de la zona
schengen desde el primero de enero de
2023 según lo aprobó este jueves la
comisión europea eso significa que las
personas que viajen desde aquel país al
resto de las 26 naciones que conforman
el área schengen no necesitarán que les
verifiquen su identidad ni cumplir con
requisitos especiales para transportarse
sin embargo rumania y Bulgaria no
obtuvieron este aval
es oficial a partir del primero de enero
Croacia entrará en el espacio schengen
una noticia celebrada especialmente por
la presidencia del Consejo de la Unión
Europea
Croacia realmente ha hecho todo lo
posible para ser parte del espacio
schengen y estamos convencidos de que es
un mensaje muy positivo para todos los
ciudadanos europeos
ahora los ciudadanos de los estados
schengen podrán entrar y salir de
Croacia sin controles fronterizos la
candidatura de zagreb fue aceptada por
unanimidad por los ministros del
interior de los 27 países que conforman
la Unión
pero no todos celebran la reunión de
este 8 de diciembre en Bélgica rumania y
Bulgaria también aspiraban a formar
parte del espacio schengen pero no
contaban con el veto de Austria que teme
que los flujos migratorios aumenten si
estos dos países entran en el acuerdo
Austria tiene más de 100.000 cruces
fronterizos ilegales de los cuales
75.000 no están registrados y esto a
pesar de ser un país sin salida al mar y
en medio de los países schengen Entonces
el sistema no está funcionando lo que
significa que tenemos que mejorarlo
significativamente primero
críticas infundadas según otros
gobiernos europeos y en particular
Rumanía
bucarest considera que cumplieron todas
las condiciones para entrar en la zona
de libre circulación
lamentamos si realmente no entendemos la
posición inflexible de Austria
inflexibilidad
durante el año pasado Rumanía ha
demostrado ser un actor de pleno derecho
en la seguridad Europea
una seguridad europea que los 27 creen
que está en peligro mientras aumentan
las llegadas irregulares la ruta
migratoria de los balcanes occidentales
representa la mayor parte del aumento
con casi 140.000 entradas desde
principios de año
el presidente chino y el príncipe
heredero de Arabia Saudita acordaron la
firma de alianzas de energía e
infraestructura por unos 30.000 millones
de dólares Ese fue el resultado del
encuentro del primer día de alto nivel
de Esta visita de estado que ha fruncido
el ceño de Estados Unidos china Busca
impulsar su economía ralentizada por la
pandemia al tiempo que fortalece lazos
con el país árabe que es un Aliado de
largo aliento de Estados Unidos y el
mayor exportador de petróleo del mundo
entre tanto otros líderes árabes
empezaron a llegar a riad para asistir a
una Cumbre con el presidente chino quien
sostendrá conversaciones con los seis
miembros del Consejo de cooperación del
Golfo
en Ucrania Las bajas temperaturas y las
condiciones que trae el invierno boreal
han dificultado las operaciones que
compromete la guerra en el terreno
nuestra enviada especial Catalina Gómez
Ángel nos explica por qué
esta lluvia es una de esas condiciones
climáticas que marca Las mayores
dificultades ahora que llega el invierno
estamos en la ciudad de nipro a cuatro
horas del frente del donbas de donde
regresamos anoche y allí nos contaban
que nos pelean en ese frente que en este
momento cuando regresa el agua y se
descongela la nieve que ha caído en los
últimos días hace imposible la vida en
esas trincheras que cada vez son más
activas especialmente en la ciudad de
backmud donde la pelea se intensifica
cada día más pero también nos cuenta que
trae sus ventajas porque esta Niebla
hace casi imposible el vuelo de los
drones que son fundamentales en esta
guerra que comenzó el 24 de febrero
solamente anoche los rusos volvían a
lanzar 14 drones de fabricación
iranídrones casi que fueron
interceptados por la defensas ucranianas
pero allí en el frente nos cuentan hay
dos tipos de drones que hacen la vida
imposible tanto para unos como para
otros el primero es el dron
una un dron Ruso que vuela bastante alto
y que tiene una cámara con bastante
precisión que ayuda a dar mensajes y a
precisar la artillería lo que hace que
los rusos están atacando con mayor
precisión en especialmente en la
posición de backboot pero los ucranianos
también usan sus drones especialmente
drones comerciales los típicos que se
consiguen en cualquier tienda que ellos
utilizan para también controlar las
posiciones enemigas y estos soldados
especialmente por los voluntarios
ucranianos estamos en una estación de
gasolina por ejemplo donde cada litro
que se consume da una un digna o la
moneda de ucraniana para comprar esos
drones que ayudan a los soldados en el
frente de batalla como todos los octavos
días del mes recordamos el secuestro del
periodista francés
este 8 de diciembre de 2022 se cumplen
20 meses desde que lo raptaron en nombre
de la libertad de prensa en su apoyo a
su familia y a sus personas más cercanas
en France 24 le seguimos dedicando
nuestros pensamientos hasta que lo
liberen así llegamos al final de las
noticias los invitamos a que sigan con
nosotros
[Música]